hello everyone
it's good to see you here and uh
I think this room is probably too big
for the audience but I think it's a kind
of expected because I think
um
there are not so many people that pay
attention to testing especially the
testing for Big Data applications it's a
field that is very ignored in industry
but I think as
you scale out your applications
and you will start to
be aware of the importance of
um that the how you should test your
applications and how you should think
about this problem so I've been working
in uh on big data problems for over 10
years so I think this talk is more about
a summary of the things that I have
learned from my own experience and from
my experience working with different
data practitioners and the Machine
learning practitioners
um maybe there are things that you don't
fully agree with but I hope it can be
inspiring thank you so before starting I
would love to
um have a quick survey like how many
people are using spark if you use spark
with your one hand if you also do
non-ad-hoc test on spark logic raise two
hands
okay okay I think not many people are
doing non-addahog tests on spark I
understand the pain point I will talk
about it how how about that how many
people are using desk
and how many people are doing now ad hoc
test on desk
oh
oh I see and how about Ray how many
people are using Rey
good and not ad hoc task test test
okay good good I think it's good um I I
know it's a pain point it's very
difficult
um and I heard about this type of
complaint almost every day
um because I work with a lot of data
practitioners and machine learning
engineers
so in today's talk I firstly I want to
have a quick introduction to the testing
types and to discuss the purposes of
those tests and then I want to talk
about the mindset
to when you design your big data
application and to see how that can
affect the testability of your
applications and now we're going to I'm
going to talk about the good practices
for testing in the end I'm going to
introduce a few guys and see how few can
help
um in casting your applications
let's start so
there are two main purposes for testing
your software and services to verify the
correctness and performance on the low
level we have unit testing integration
testing and the regression testing and
regression testing can be in the form of
unit testing and integration testing and
on the high level for correctness
normally you do acceptance testing and
for performance normally you do stress
testing
and therefore stress testing is mainly
for
throughput and latency and for
acceptance acceptance testing in the
context of Big Data people normally do
spot check
or data validation I will talk about it
later
so
talking about the testing strategy if we
just pick unit testing integration
testing and the acceptance acceptance
testing from top down we move from
implementation focused to data focused
we move from technology driven to
business logic driven
and if we talk about
um the benefit of uh in in the context
of Big Data then we'll see that
the higher level testings they're easier
faster and cheaper because they do not
require so much context of the
distributed system
and of course the higher level testings
they have better coverage so
the purpose of like I mean the strategy
of testing is you should try to move the
your testing logic to upper level as
much as you can but of course every
layer will have their own purposes and
you should keep all of them every every
testing is important
so now let's talk about the mindset when
you design your big data applications
how that can affect the testability
the first thing you must have a strong
sense of separation of logic so in my
opinion there should be layers of logic
the first layer should be your
co-computing logic
it should be framework agnostic and this
part should be the most uni testable
part
and it should be well covered by unit
tests on second level I call it
orchestration logic or you can call it
something else but it's framework
dependent framework I mean spark desk
and rail any other distributed backends
and this one so if you use spark dancing
and Rey actually it's testable but the
problem is sometimes it's very slow to
test for example spark is the typical
example if you want to start a local
spark cluster and test some simple logic
it's probably fine but if you have
hundreds of such tests it will take very
long time to finish why I know that
because I'm the creator of fuke and if
you in order to cover everything we have
to have hundreds of unit tests just on
spark.com Ray take very long time to
finish
um so the last layer should be framework
specific logic including how you set up
the cluster how you tear down the
cluster this is purely
um like a infrastructure oriented logic
it's the most difficult ones to test so
if you want to test probably you should
cover that by acceptance tests
now let's take a look at the example to
explain the separation so we have a data
frame and we want to group by G and then
for each group we want to subtract the
mean of V from V so it's a very simple
example right so how if we want to
implement this in spark here is an
implementation
as you can see to be honest this is a
very bad implementation why because
there is no separation of logic as you
can see that in this function you create
a spark cluster you try to initialize
the smart cluster inside this function
and another thing you have to be aware
is you try to use a Lambda function
to do the group by applying semantic
but this Lambda function itself is
actually totally spark independent
right so if you design your application
in this way then it's impossible to do
the Simplicity unit testing probably you
can do some integration testing but it's
also very difficult what you can do is
acceptance testing and maybe I think
what people commonly do is just do some
spot check
so this is a very bad design
in order to solve this problem yes it's
a little bit more code but this code is
in a much better shape much better
structure
um and you can see that for the first
part your cool Computing logic has
nothing to do with spark you should
fully cover this with unit testing and
for the spark dependent logic
you also move out the creation to the
third function and in the spark
depending on the logic you just try to
distribute the data frame and the method
and to run this depend distributed
right so with this design you have
separated to three layers and you can do
unit test on the first layer integration
on second
acceptance test on the third
so it's a relatively better better
design but I will talk about if there
can be an even better design later
the second mindset I want to say is you
should try to avoid
the framework driven mindset
so
I talk about three layers but actually
you should try to always try to maximize
the frame framework agnostic layer
where you can do all types of unit
testing you should try to minimize the
framework dependent layer so that to
reduce the size of integration test and
for framework specific logic of course
we want to minimize it but more
importantly you want to standardize it
and you want to centralize it so you do
not have to have too many acceptance
tests to cover that
so let's take a look at another example
we have a customer logic here we want to
process this data frame it has full
columns a b c and d they're all strings
there are some nouns so for each row
if there are more than one no no values
we will sort these values concatenate
them and put them into the column e
okay but if there are too many nouns we
will just drop this row
so this logic is is very specific right
but you know the question is how we
implement this okay so
if we want to use spark to solve this
problem the first thing came to our mind
will be
using map partitions right you if you
want to use map partitions you will use
you will have to implement a function
with the iterator of rows as you input
but the problem is as soon as you write
this function you will notice your core
logic now is tightly coupled with spark
no matter when you want to test this
core logic which represents the business
logic you have to have a spark cluster
even locally I mean either locally or
distributedly right so you do not have a
good separation of logic it's not very
unit testable
if you want to increment this using task
and task is pandaslike
so the first thing came into mind coming
to your mind probably I should use Panda
Supply if you use Penance Supply okay
the logic should look like this way and
the input will be a panda series because
this is required by a panel Supply
and it looks better because this
co-logic is totally unit testable and it
has nothing to do with a desk
but the problem is the collage does not
cover everything of your requirements if
you look at here the filtering logic
is left out of your core logic so in
order to test things end to end you
still have to have an integration test
test on my app in order to test the
whole logic
if you want to implement this already
now it looks much better because Ray is
not like sparkle dusk it's new it has
very few options so you think less and
you can only use map batches on dataset
and in map batches very nicely they can
take a dependence data frame as input
and output and they will just distribute
this core logic to different data frames
and the way you have this requirement
you will find okay now I can write very
modularized code right the input is just
a sub
subset of the entire data frame as
dependence data frame and then I just
write this very pandas native code to
solve this problem
right so now if you look at this
structure is much better because this
core logic is a full representation of
your business requirement and the
framework dependent part is very minimal
right looks very optimal
and to be fair if you know more about
Sparkle dusk they also have special API
to take this pandas data frame and they
also have the similar function like not
purchasing rate so it's not the only
Advantage I mean it's it's not an
advantage of Ray actually every
distributed Frameworks they have
right but is this the best solution
so now let's take a look at the
alternative information implementation
of this core logic
remote but here what we try to do is
actually we just try to wrap this
process function this process function
just takes very simple just takes an
iterable of lists as input iterable list
as output then what you can find is I
only need four lines of code to solve
this problem
it has no dependency on any framework
very expressive very simple right the
things you have to do is the data
conversion you have to convert the data
frame to a two-dimensional array and
then process and construct it back to
appendix different
why I put this logic here
I compare the speed
it's a surprise right Panda's native
approach
is 50 times slower than this python
native approach so it's a it's a big
surprise right so if we take a step
further just to think about it from the
very beginning if you don't know pandas
if you don't know spark dark sky ray
what will be the first thing came into
mind actually it is this function
because this function has nothing to do
with any package
simple and expressive is also the
fastest version but what prevents us
from from having this idea
at the first I mean as as the as the
first idea right so I think the problem
is we are so distracted by Frameworks we
we are going to use
the common thing I see from the data
practitioners are if they want to solve
a problem problem the first question is
how do I use XYZ to solve the problem
but I think if we can change our mindset
what can we do
as much as possible before using XYZ I
think that kind of mindset is is
healthier because it's more a business
driven so it can help you to isolate
your problem just to focus on solving
your business problem instead of like
Get getting distracted by the special
features of different Frameworks
that is at least to me I think it's it's
a very useful mindset when I made that
change I find my programming skill
improved a lot
okay now let's talk about about good
practices
I know a lot of people talking about NYC
taxi in this conference because it's New
York city so again I'm going to use this
example but no technical details so the
background is
uh this is a public data set and the the
data date ranges from 2009 to 2022. on
monthly basis and each file represents a
month of data the size ranges from 50 to
150 megabytes and each file contains 20
columns we only need two which are shown
here and each row represents a write
and there are 242 different locations
in this PO location ID what we want to
do is for each po location ID
we get we aggregate the data to get the
hourly total number of pickups so it's a
Time series we want to use that time
series to train a forecasting model
and to predict the next Horizon the
total pickups in the next given Horizon
okay so given that in mind
here is a high level workflow
it's very simple to implement this task
like get one month of data aggregated by
location an hour
like for example if you do that in
pandas probably it just takes you a few
minutes to do that right so and then you
just want to merge everything and
re-partition by location and sort by
hour now you have for each location you
will have a Time series and now for each
location I can adjust the train and
predict distributedly and in the end we
just merge the predicted value and save
to a file
so just given this workflow I think I I
can call this big data workflow although
I mean it's just if it is several
hundred gigabytes I think it's fair to
cause it's a big big data workflow how
can we test it
so this is what I commonly see from
um the people I work with
so because getting one month of data
aggregate location hour is pretty
trivial probably just a few lines of
code and given any decent distributed
backhand spark does hand they all have
very simple method to run this
distributedly on the full history people
tend to run this like implement this
with a few lines of code and then
wrongful history immediately
after they run the full history
they just do ad hoc spot check
okay and then feel oh it's good it's
good then what do they do they just
write the whole bunch of code and to
finish the pipeline
okay after this what they do they just
run from the very beginning run the
whole Pipeline and then do another spot
check
if it is good they will just say okay I
have tested this application works good
let's ship it but when you ship it you
don't even have any written test right
everything is ad hoc
so this and another thing is worth to
mention is that when you run things in
full scale it's not take like seconds or
minutes it can take hours
but with this kind of
um like a design then you when every
time if you have any problem
you you find out in your sports hack you
have to restart from the beginning the
iteration is actually a lot slower and
also think about using a cluster to run
this can also be very expensive so it's
not a good way to develop your
application it's not a good way to test
it's not optimal now let's talk about a
better strategy to do this
so getting one month of data aggregate
it's trivial right but it's also trivial
to add unit tests right so why not just
immediately add a unit test as soon as
you finish this local logic
implementation
it's not hard right and for the Second
Step Union data repartition and sort
this one you can adjust the right you
can just provide some mock data and then
to assert an output so for this step
it's also trivial right so you should
also write a unit test as soon as you
finish the implementation
a third step of training and predict for
one location so you have two ways one
way is just to get one month of data of
a certain location and then maybe save
that as a temporary as a file for
testing and then you can just load that
file here and to do the test or you can
just manually construct some data for
testing right it's not difficult so you
can have another unit test here to cover
it
and all these tests if we run them it
shouldn't take a few seconds but think
about that if there is any problem in
the implementation you quickly turn
around because you can you can quickly
make some changes and run the unit test
again so iteration is much faster and
after you get everything together now
you want to chain them together right so
wait let's do one more month of data
just do one more month so now this first
step is multitask and let's pick one
more location to to do train and predict
now this step is also multitask now
let's implement the union or unsafe okay
this is an end-to-end pipeline now but
you are not processing a lot of data is
still very limited amount of data
end-to-end so at this step what should
we do
we can add an integration test now
so think about that the integration test
is testing this although not not at full
scale but structure wise there is no
change if you want to run full scale or
partial scale right
right so at this step this is the best
time to have an integration test
it will also give you very fast
iteration if there you find anything any
problems in it after you finish this
integration test let's first do the full
test uh like a full run of the first
step and here
instead of small check I strongly
recommend you add a data validation step
in your workflow
always prefer data validation because
why the data validation has so many
benefits one major benefit is that when
you add this to a workflow the
validation not only happens before your
production it happens during a
production as well
so you always have that kind of
protection right and this data
validation should be like a data
contract a description of a data
contract
and this data contract will guarantee
that the bad data will not Flow To The
Next Step
and then just around the full scale on
train and predict have another data
validation step as acceptance test
so to summarize best practices
first of all I want to say try to be
test driven I know it's very hard it's
very hard
um people feel it's very challenging to
change that mindset to change that
development style but try uh I I did a
pure test driven for one year it's just
amazing experience you will get very
slow from the beginning but then you
will get faster faster faster and in the
end you don't fit you don't fix bugs you
just keep creating new things and just
enjoy the development experience
um second thing I think you should
always try to unit test the small data
and the cool logic unit
you should do integration tests before
running at full scale
to save time and money
I should try to add data validation
steps in the workflow as you acceptance
tests
small check is is useful but you should
standardize it and I think for big data
problems data validation is the most
reasonable way
okay and the last but not the least I
think tests should reflect uh the
requirement of each logical unit
it should be the most readable part of
your code so try to make the test just
like a document
it will be very beautiful
okay so I talked about mindsets and good
practices now the question is
how
to enforce the good practices
how to have a very healthy mindset so
here I want to introduce Fugue and I
hope it can help you shape your mindset
and also to enforce some of the good
practices
so if you get the unified abstraction
of computing Frameworks
so on the local side we have different
Computing Frameworks
we have sqlite.db as the SQL solution we
have native python
we also have pandas
on the distribution side on distributed
system side we have spark.s and Ray as
the major players
of distributed Solutions
just the bridge between local and
distributed environment because it has
the abstraction so it unifies how you
use the the different Computing
Frameworks
and you can just use the same exactly
same logic same like a expression of
your logic or small data using local
execution engine or you apply that on
big data on a distributed execution
engine so field guarantees the same
behavior on different environments
so what's the value of Fugue in terms of
testing it removes the framework
dependent logic so remember that we talk
about we should have three layers of
Logics when designed right we should try
to minimize the first layer maximize the
first layer minimize the second layer
and third layer or few can do it can
simply remove the second layer
so instead of having a framework
dependent layer now everything is
framework agnostic the field abstraction
itself is from agnostic so remember that
it has a unified interface for local and
distributed you only need to use that
abstraction to run on a local engine
then you can do the unit test so when
you test your distributed logic you do
not even need a distributed environment
so I get rid of the need of an expensive
environment for unit testing or
integration testing
so let's record the first example we
have three layers right and the problem
is
for this my app we still need to have a
spark cluster to test it
how can we improve this
so what we can do is instead of writing
the spark specific code you just import
the transform from field and rewrite it
in this way notice now the input of my
app becomes a DF which is any type and
engine is also at any time so what does
that mean that means now this app is
framework agnostic and skill agnostic so
if we want to UNI test it just
input a pandas data frame this
Transformer will just return appendix
data frame you can just use this to test
your logic
just using a local environment but if
you want to productionize that you want
to scale out
simply provide the spark session you
constructed or that's client array and
you can also replace this data frame
from appendix data frame
to a spark data frame that's data frame
array data set they all work so this the
transition and the data conversion are
all handled by the field level and the
field level is well tested we always
maintain 100 test coverage on our site
okay so that means with this
implementation
you no longer depend on any specific
distributed vacant
look at the second example customer
logic
this is simple and fast right how can we
scale this out
again you only need to add one line of
code
still the transform function
so what's the magic here so look at the
first function
the subtract mean the input is pandas
different output is pen is different
the second function input and output are
iterables
so actually what field can do is
as long as you have the type annotation
figures knows how to do the data
conversion for example in this case if
this my app is running on Ray it will
also use a map of edges but the data
conversion part you have seen in the
previous example is automatically
handled on the field level so you don't
have to really write those kind of
boiler play code in order to adapt to
your most expressive and the most
reasonable implementation you just focus
on the most reasonable way to do your
thing and feel can adapt to your way so
that's the magic of you
if we take a look at the third example
the major benefit is until the
integration test
you will we finish the integration test
we may not need any distributed backends
so everything would just you can just
run everything locally without the
distributed backends and the behavior
should be exactly the same way in switch
that to a to like spark.com Ray and on
validation step actually I gave a talk
last year on Pi data Global how you can
use Fugue with Pandera and the Great
Expectations to quickly scale those data
validations so maybe you can use that as
the additional step
to do the distributed data validation on
at the beginning of each major steps
so beyond that let's talk about SQL
so we all know that SQL is not very unit
testable right spark SQL I guess no one
is testing it
especially when your sequel source is
not even a local data frame think about
that this is very common in different
companies I just want to select
something from a hive table but I
actually add a lot of logic to this
decode so now the question is how can we
test this
this is not testable people I think the
excuse is that the source is just a hive
table it's not testable but actually if
you use Fugue this is fully testable
what you can do two things one is
because we can fully understand the
sequel so it's markable you can just say
Okay I want this Hive Dark Souls table
to be something else
you can just provide a pen that's
different
and another thing is instead of running
this on spark
you can just run this on Doug DB
now the logic is actually executed on
duckdb and the source hive.src table is
already the mock table dependence data
frame so the output will also be a log
data local data frame either Arrow table
or panda say frame you can just do the
local unit testing on it so it's fully
unit testable even not without Spark
and
here is a advanced example so this is
something that few users often do
it's a it's called field sequel fugo is
a sequel that's beyond the standard
sequel the traditional sequel because we
can have extra syntax to invoke those uh
python functions as the extensions
Advanced UDF idea and what you can do is
as the first step you just still get the
data from hive and the Second Step you
want to pre-partition by location and
pre-soot by timestamp and using this
train predictor function on each of the
partitions and this is a trained
predicted function itself can just be a
very independent pendous function and
you should fully unit test it now the
question is how do you how do you test
this without even using spark this is
like integration test right you have to
do an integration test end to end
without using spark how can we do that
again you can just use this FC code
and you can mark the input I have SRC
table
and just provide the path
a local path and then you just run this
on that DB
after this a local file will be written
and then you can just assert the data in
the
in the output file so
um to be honest this is still not
perfect for example for this data trunk
this function luckily for both.db and
the spark they have the same signatures
but if there are some other functions it
may not be compatible but the bottom
line is the bottom line is
you can just run this on a local spark
it is I mean it's not perfect now you
have to get spark involved to test your
logic but at least the input data is
much smaller and you can do some sort of
integration test otherwise you can only
do acceptance tests because this input
is a hive table
so
what field can do is try to push your
tests up to Upper levels as much as as
we can yeah
okay so in summary
um
all types of tests are useful for
different purposes we need to be
strategic about that
and application design really matters
you should try to separate out the
framework independent logic and minimize
the dependent part this is mindset
and you should not be driven by tools
tools is working for you you are not
working for the tools
and if you can reduce the dependency on
distributed backhands and simplify and
accelerate the Big Data pipeline testing
and iteration but again also field is
also a tool so I mean even you are
interested in this
I think don't driven by tools always
hoes I I hope I hope whatever you do
try to start with a fresh mind
thank you
[Applause]
yes please
I think of course working with big data
is that very often it's far from perfect
and one of the advantages of the spot
checking method is that if there are
small imperfections at the beginning of
the data but they don't affect the
aggregate output so you don't get
distracted by them with unit tests is
there some concern that you will get
distracted by a lot of bad data that
doesn't really impact the output that
much okay so I think your question is
because big data has a lot of noise so
smooth if you just test on the small
unit you could just get distracted by a
lot of noises
I think I think this is a valid this is
a valid thing first of all uh if you
know that your data has a lot of uh like
noises you should have different layer
of tests like higher level higher level
tests like for example acceptance tests
things like that they should be more
resistant to the noise and on a lower
level
I would say that why not just
intentionally add some noise and see how
the system reacts to those I think it
could I mean I mean it's to me I think
adding noise to the test the case is is
a very good testic case that we should
test
that's just my opinion
yeah I don't think it's a bad thing
to be honest thank you
yeah please
uh I we don't use rdd we just use only
use data frame
yes yeah that was my concern because and
I
function so um so rdd to be honest is
not the first class citizen of spark
um so I mean um in the field framework
we try to make that more clear that data
frame is the way to go actually this is
also what the Sparks suggests people to
do try to
do your things in data frames like
um if you try to use rdd it's a sign
that maybe you should think more about I
mean think twice and see okay should you
use rdd or should you use data frame so
I I think I think
um so in in the field in the field World
it will not let you use rdd rdd is a
special concept of spark
but in your example you were using my
previous function so what do you use in
compute so you using fugue
so let me see
you're just talking about
Our member partitions uh so in field we
have two ways one is we would we will
convert to rdds and then to do the thing
I mean the the things I showed and
another way is if you if you enable
pandas UDF we will just use pandas UDF
which is a new way
um it's much much faster than map
partitions yeah yeah so we internally
yes sometimes we have to convert to rdd
to process but we will prefer pendants
UDF
their way of entirely escaped the early
functionality because we
um I mean best effort sometimes we
cannot skip uh the using of rdd yeah
yeah it's not always no always yeah but
I think in most cases we can totally
skip using rdd
yes please uh that's a last example you
had was the was a
that's a sampling of the test data
there's few support any sort of sampling
sampling of this data just give me the
highest level and then I simply explore
you and then I give you something
that is a very very good question
actually I didn't show the iteration
actually sampling is a very important
technique when you want to do big data
application testing uh I'm sorry I
didn't mention but thank you for the
reminder so what we uh normally do I
mean in the Practical situation I will
separate this pipeline to two parts and
the first part I would just maybe sample
like a point zero zero zero one percent
to get a data frame and then in the
second part I will keep continue
iteration so sampling is a very
important technique to break the lineage
and also to provide the smaller data for
for iteration on the next step yeah
thank you it's included in the field
Library yes yes and it's often used yeah
it's often used
okay okay thank you very much
[Applause]